Speaker 1: I come to you today to tell you that
Chris Christie's polling is now up 150% since he
announced he was running for president. However,
this puts him at two and a half. So, listen,
percentage wise, things are going in the right
direction for Chris Christie. The clearly the
most sane and rational person running in the 2024
Republican primary. But is it going to be enough?
I don't know. So let's take a look at some data.
Chris Christie announced that he was running on
June 6th, but we learned that he was running on
May 31st, June 1st. So we're going to look at how
polling has changed for the Republican candidates,
the top ones between June 1st and today. Trump,
for example, was at 53 when Christie announced,
and he is now at 52. So Trump is down 2% since
Christie's announcement, DeSantis is totally
flat at absolutely flat, totally not woke at
all. DeSantis was at 22 and he's still at 22. So
he has not seen any polling change. Mike Pence was
at four but is now at six. Pence has gained 50%,
Nikki Haley unchanged four and four. Tim Scott was
at 2%, Now polling 4%. He has gained 100% support,
doubling it. And then there is Chris Christie
who was polling 1%, announced his candidacy
and is now polling 2.5%. That is a gain of 150%
percent. Now, am I being serious? Well, I'm being
serious, but I'm also going to be honest with you
about small numbers. Small numbers in general
can be inaccurate or meaningless in exactly
these sorts of situations when you're looking
at changes because such small numbers can be
affected by rounding, they can be affected by data
truncation, they can be affected by inflation,
context, sample size. So for example, if someone
goes up from 1 to 2% in polling, it's technically
an increase of 100%. You've gone from 1 to 2.
It's mostly meaningless because these numbers
are so small that they really may not reflect
the preferences of the population. And these
small changes can easily be influenced by random
error measurement uncertainty. Sampling bias,
etc.. So you do get rid of a little bit of this
by using averages of polls, which we are doing.
Is Chris Christie gaining? I believe Chris
Christie is gaining. But to say that he has
really gained 150% support since his announcement
maybe is a bit further than we can go. What we
are starting to get a picture of, and this is
really important, is that it may not be so simple
to significantly shift massive amounts of
support in the Republican primary. Trump's
now been indicted twice. DeSantis went from
a potential candidate to a real candidate.
Trump's basically flat. DeSantis is basically
flat. Nobody else is polling any more than 6%.
So if there's any real takeaway right now, forget
about, oh, they were at one, now they're at three
or whatever the case may be. The big takeaway
for me is that it is proving difficult to see
significant moves in Republican voters. The next
milestone, of course, becomes, well, number one,
does Trump get indicted between July and September
in Georgia? And number two, in late August,
the first Republican primary debate will take
place on Fox News. Bret BAIER will be hosting
it. Does Trump show up to that debate and
does the debate performance actually shift
the numbers in any serious way? We have plenty
of time to think about that. This is where the
polling is today. We're going to take the quickest
break. Make sure you're subscribed on YouTube at
YouTube.com, slash the David Paxman show. And
the show will simply continue in a moment.